. OKAY WILL BRING THIS
MEETING TO ORDER. WE HAVE A
BRIEF HEARING MEMBERS- THIS
AFTERNOON- WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
CONSENT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE
ITEM THREE ON YOUR GENDER WE
HAVE TWO BILLS- WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM SELMA RIVAS AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY SIX AND SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN- MYSTERY OF IS IF
YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD AND-
APPROACH THE- PRESENT WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHILE YOU
PREPARE. SEARCH PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL GRAY. GRAY HAIR BIGELOW
BIGELOW HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE BERMAN. BONTA.
BRO BRO HERE COOLEY. COOPER
YEAH COOPER HERE DAILY DAILY
HERE GALLAGHER GALLAGHER HERE
GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON HERE
JONES SAWYER HERE JONES SAWYER
HERE LACKEY HERE LACKEY HERE
LOW. MATHIS VOEPEL. QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HERE RIVAS HERE
RIVAS HERE RUBIO RUBIO HERE
SALAS SALAS HERE. OKAY WE HAVE
A QUORUM ESTABLISHED WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I THINK I HEAR A
MOTION FOR MISTER JONES SAWYER
A SECOND FROM MISTER DALY.
CERTAIN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE GRAY AYE
GRAY AYE BIGELOW. I BIGELOW
HIGH AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I'VE BERMAN. BONTA.
RO RO HI COOLEY COOPER COOPER
AYE DALY ON DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE LOW.
MATHIS VOEPEL QUIRK SILVA WORK
SILVA I RIVAS RIVAS AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS AYE. OKAY
SEC HOURS A DOT ORG IS A
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED WE WILL NOW
HEAR FROM MYSTERY OF US THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES-
PROUD TO PRESENT A COUPLE OF
BILLS HERE START WITH- AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY SIX AND FIRST
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS AND I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT THIS LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY IN
REDUCES FIRE RISKS. HERE
CALIFORNIA. I PRESENT TO THE
FIRE SAFETY ACT IT PROHIBITS.
THE CIGARETTES FROM BEING SOLD
IN OUR STATE UNLESS THEY MEET
NATION WIDE REDUCED IGNITION
STANDARDS NOW THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL IS IN CHARGE OF
REVIEWING SUBMISSIONS TO VERIFY
FIRE SAFETY. BUT THESE PRODUCTS
ARE DEEMED APPROVED SHOULD THE
FIRE MARSHAL TAKE NO ACTION
WITHIN- THE TEN- BUSINESS DAYS
AND THAT HAS LED TO MANY
MANUFACTURE PROPOSE MARKINGS
BEING APPROVED BY DEFAULT SO
THAT'S WITHOUT PROPER REVIEW SO
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE THE FIRE SAFETY ACT AND
IT EXTENDS THE TEN DAY
AUTOMATIC APPROVAL- APPROVAL
ROLE. TO THE THIRD EXCUSE WITH
THE THIRTY DAYS- SO AGAIN THIS
BILL WOULD STRAIGHTEN THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE FIRE SAFETY
ACT TO REDUCE THE RISK OF FIRES
CAUSED BY- SOME CIGARETTES AND
SO WITH US HERE TODAY ARE- SOME
REPRESENTATIVES FROM- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE THE
FIRST IS THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL RENUKA GEORGE AND ALSO-
KAREN LEAF WHO'S THE SENIOR
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS RUNNING COULD GEORGE AND I'M
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHAT THE OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ON BEHALF OF EIJI Và
SERRA I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY SIX AMENDS CALIFORNIA
FIRE SAFETY ACCESS TO MOVE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE ACT OVER
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE WHO WILL ENSURE THAT
CIGARETTES SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
MEET SPECIFIC SELF
EXTINGUISHING A FIRE SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS. HER CURRENTLY THE
FIRE SAFETY ACT PROHIBITS
CIGARETTES FROM BEING SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA UNLESS THE
MANUFACTURER PROVIDES THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL WITH CERTIFICATION
ESTABLISHING THAT ITS PRODUCTS
HAVE BEEN MANUFACTURED AND
TESTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
CERTAIN NATIONWIDE REDUCED.
IGNITION PROPENSITY STANDARDS.
THOSE CIGARETTES THAT HAVE THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN CERTIFIED THAT
THEY MEET THE STANDARDS ARE
HAVE NOT BEEN APPROVED BY THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL CANNOT BE
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED AT
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL DOES NOT
TAKE ACTION WITHIN TEN DAYS
AFTER THE CIGARETTE
MANUFACTURERS PROVIDE THEIR
CERTIFICATION THE CIGARETTES
ARE AUTOMATICALLY. I DEEMED
APPROVED BY DEFAULT THE TWENTY
GENERAL'S OFFICE IS THE STATE
AGENCY CHARGED WITH ENFORCING
THE ACT AND ENSURING THAT ONLY
FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES ARE SOLD
IN CALIFORNIA. ADMINISTRATION
OF THE ACT IS VITAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S TOBACCO
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS
UNFORTUNATELY IN RECENT YEARS
DURING TO FUNDING CONSTRAINTS
THERE HAS BEEN LIMITED REVIEW
OF THE FIRE SAFETY
CERTIFICATIONS. APPROVAL OF
PROPOSED MARKINGS BY DEFAULT
HAS IMPAIR THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY.
ULTIMATELY AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
SIX IS A GOOD GOVERNANCE AND
EFFICIENCY MEASURE THE BILL
REDUCES COSTS FOR THE STATE'S
BECAUSE IT CONSOLIDATES THE
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT OF
THE FIRE SAFETY AFTER ONE STATE
AGENCY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHICH IT USES THE
NUMBER OF SUBMISSIONS
REGULATORY. COMMISSION AND
REGULATORY FEES FOR THE MYSTERY
TO ME. THANK YOU FOR I'M
INTERESTED. FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S AFRICA VARGAS
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE STRONG SUPPORT WE WERE
ONE OF THE ORIGINAL CO SPONSORS
OF THIS LEGISLATION WITH THAT
MISTER CHRIS BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AND- SO THANK YOU
FOR MAKING ME FEEL OLD. ANY
PUBLIC SUPPORT. SEEING NONE OF
THE OPPOSITION. SIGNAL RATE
BACK TO THE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS WHICH COOPER HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE G. STAFF IS
FAR AS THE ILLICIT CIGARETTES
THE BLACK MARKET- I WAS THERE
MAKE IT IS DIFFERENT. WHAT IS
IT IS OFFICE DOING TO COMBAT
THAT. I WOULD HAVE DONE. THANK
YOU- FOR THE QUESTION IT
TURNING GENERAL'S OFFICE IS
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT- THE SALES
OF ILLICIT CIGARETTES IN THE
STATE ALL IN IS TAKING A NUMBER
OF ACTIONS OF THE IN TO ENFORCE
RECENTLY THE- CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE SUED
THE ACTUALLY THE UNITED STATES
POSTAL SERVICE. BECAUSE IT IS
ACCEPTING FOR DELIVERY AND
DELIVERING TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS LARGE QUANTITIES OF
CIGARETTES THAT ARE COMING FROM
FOREIGN SOURCES- WITHOUT
COMPLYING WITH APPLICABLE STATE
AND FEDERAL LAWS AND THIS IS
ALSO- A VIOLATION OF- THE-
PACKED ACT WHICH IS A FEDERAL
STATUTE THAT REGULATES THE
DELIVERY OF CIGARETTES- IN THE
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES WE
ALSO TAKE IN ANY NUMBER OF
ACTIONS AGAINST OTHER ENTITIES
CIGARETTE MANUFACTURERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS. THAT HAVE SOLD
ILLEGAL CIGARETTES IN OURS OUR
PUBLIC WEBSITE HAS QUITE A BIT
OF INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS THAT WE
HAVE- FILED AND THE RESULTS AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU A LINK
TO IT IF YOU LIKE. SO MOST WAS
A BLACK MARKET ISSUE THEN
CORRECT. YEAH PROBLEMS THEY
THEY ARE- THEY ARE. OFF
DIRECTORY CIGARETTES THAT ARE
UNLAWFUL FOR SALE IN THE STATE
SO I GUESS MY CONCERN IS RIGHT
NOW REVENUE A BIG PROBLEM WITH
VAPING- BOTH THE BLACK MARKET.
THERE REALLY HASN'T BEEN
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT MADE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT- TO THAT MARKET YET
SO YOU'VE GOT YOU COMPETING
WITH THAT SO I MEAN. WE KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES
THAN THEY DID AWAY WITH BEANIE
SO- I'M JUST TRY TO FIGURE OUT.
GOING FORWARD WHAT IS A PLANT
MAGES OFFICE TO DEAL WITH THAT.
KNOWING THAT YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE- VAPING BLACK MARKET
ALSO WELL WE ARE CERTAINLY
CONCERNED ABOUT ILLEGAL SALES
OF- LIKE TRONIC CIGARETTES AS
WELL- THERE WAS I THINK A FAIR
AMOUNTOF PUBLICITY ASSOCIATED
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
DECISION TO SUE JEWEL. FOR A
VARIETY OF- VIOLATIONS OF STATE
LAW WE DID THAT IN NOVEMBER WE
ARE ALWAYS. TRIED IN AN
EFFICIENT WAY TO- ENFORCE THE
APPLICABLE LAWS AGAINST ALL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS BUT ON THE
VAPING ISSUES MOST OF IT IS NOT
COMING FROM JEWEL BLACK MARKET.
CANNABIS ANOTHER BLACK MARKET
PRODUCTS THAT'S THAT'S THE CRUX
OF THE PROBLEM CORRECT. WELL WE
SOON ACTUAL BECAUSE WE HAVE A
GOOD FAITH BELIEF THAT JEWEL
HAS OPERATED OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH A NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
LAWS THAT SAID THERE CERTAINLY
ARE OTHER ENTITIES THAT ARE
SELLING. TOBACCO PRODUCTS
INCLUDING VAPING PRODUCTS-
WITHOUT FULLY COMPLIED WITH
CALIFORNIA LAW AND WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK INTO ALL THAT ACTIVITY.
MY HOPE IS THAT WE JUST TO DO A
BETTER JOB OBVIOUSLY THE AG'S
OFFICE HAS A LOT OF BALLS IN
THEIR LOT TO JUGGLE AND THE
LOCALS THERE DOWN TO GROUND
LEVEL THEY KNOW THAT THEIR
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS MISS FOSTER
DOING SAID LEAD TO SEE MORE
PUSH DOWN IT REALLY TIRESOME
THESE FOLKS. THAT ARE MAKING A
LOT OF MONEY OFF THESE. THE
BLACK MARKET CIGARETTES RIGHT
AND IT REALLY HIT WITH ASSET
FORFEITURE. AS IS THE EIGHTY
THOUGHT ABOUT REALLY. DOING
THAT ARE GOING AFTER HIM THE
SUBSTANTIAL WAY BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THE FINES ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT CERTAINLY- UNDERS
SOME LAWS- ASSET THAT SEIZURE
OF CIGARETTES AND FORFEITURE OF
CIGARETTES IS PERMISSIBLE THOSE
THAT ARE SOLD WITHOUT- BEING ON
OUR STATE TOBACCO DIRECTORY-
TARA TALKING THEIR MONEY
ANOTHER CIGARETTES PARDON I'M
TALKING THEIR MONEY. THE
PROBLEMS THEY MAKE- YEAH YOU
CAN YOU SEE THE CIGARETTE THREE
LEGAL TALK ABOUT ASSET
FORFEITURE SEASON THEIR MONEY
IN IN PROPERTY. WELL WHAT I
WOULD HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT TO
ASCERTAIN- THE- APPLICABLE LAWS
THAT WOULD GIVE US THE
AUTHORITY TO GO AGAINST ASSETS
FATHER THEY ON THE CIGARETTES
THEMSELVES. IF I MAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK YOU KNOW WERE
APPRECIATIVE OF THIS CONTINUING
DISCUSSION WERE OBVIOUSLY
EXPLORING ALL OF THESE VARIOUS
AVENUES THAT WE CAN- IN IN THIS
FIGHT AGAINST- IN BLACK MARKET
OF CIGARETTES IN VAPING I'M I
THINK WITH RESPECT TO THIS BILL.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
BAND WITH WE ACTUALLY THINK
THAT THIS WOULD HELP STREAMLINE
SOME OF THE- BOTH THE EFFORTS
IN THE- AND THE SUBMISSIONS
RIGHT NOW TO MAKE THIS ACTUALLY
EASIER FOR THE AG TO ENFORCE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY A LOT OF
IT ON THE IN THE TO DEATH BUT
YOU ONLY HAVE SO MUCH CAPACITY.
IS THE IT IS OFFICE. SO WHAT'S
MORE IMPORTANT THE VAPING
ISSUE. FOR THE BLACK MARKET
CIGARETTES AND ONCE AGAIN YOU
HAVE ONLY SO MANY AGENTS. THEY
CAN GO OUT OF FORCE THESE LAWS
AND DEAL WITH THIS SO. I JUST
YOU CAN'T DO IT. WELL WHAT WE
BELIEVE THIS ILL ACTUALLY HELP
STREAMLINE ALL OF THAT AND
ULTIMATELY. IF. OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. MR GALLAGHER
LOOKS LIKE HE HAS A BRIEF
QUESTION. YOUNG MY CAN MY
CONCERN IS I MEAN CERTAINLY IS
A GOOD PROGRAM- BUT I DON'T
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A SUFFICIENT
JUSTIFICATION FOR MOVING IT
FROM THE FIRE MARSHALL TO THE
AG'S OFFICE. AND LOOKED QUITE
FRANKLY THE AG'S OFFICE IS
HAVING A TROUBLE DOING THE
THINGS THAT IS ALREADY TASKED
WITH DOING PRIMARILY GETTING
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF FELONS
AND OTHER PROHIBITED PERSONS.
IS STILL WAY BEHIND ON THAT AND
I WOULD MUCH RATHER SEE THEIR
ATTENTION FOCUSED ON THE
IMPORTANT ITEMS THAT HAS BEEN
TASKED WITH AS OF TODAY RATHER
THAN ADDING A PROGRAM AND I
THINK IS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER IS POINTED OUT. THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE. I THINK FULLY
FLESHED OUT BEFORE WE JUST HAND
OVER- THIS PROGRAM I MEAN THERE
IS THE- BLACK MARKET THE NO
CANNABIS AS WELL WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE ENFORCEMENT OF THOSE
THINGS- I THINK THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT ASSETS ASSET FORFEITURE
IS A GOOD ONE- AND SHOULD MAYBE
BE PART OF THIS AS WELL- SO I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW THAT I'M
READY TO JUST. SAY YEAH LET'S
GO AHEAD AND HAND OVER THIS
PROGRAM WHEN AGAIN I DON'T
THINK THERE'S BEEN THE
SUFFICIENT SUFFICIENT
JUSTIFICATION OR YOU KNOW THE
BACKGROUND. AS TO HOW THIS
COULD ALL WORK VERY
COMPREHENSIVELY- IN THE AG'S
OFFICE. APPARENTLY MR GARGAN I
HAVE DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS OF
BRIEF. MR BIGELOW. AND SO
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I CAN REALLY
BRIEFLY- HAVE REALLY BRIEFLY I
YOU KNOW I THINK ONE THING
THAT'S BEEN OVERLOOKED IS- WITH
THIS BILL- ME- I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS ABOUT EFFICIENCIES-
BUT CERTAINLY MODERNIZATION IS
SOMETHING THAT I CARE ABOUT AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CURRENT
PROCESS THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
HAS A PAPER FORM AND MANUALLY
ENTERS MOST OF THIS DATA TO A
SPREADSHEET AND SO THE IDEA
BEHIND THIS IS THAT WHEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SHOULD ASSUME
THIS RESPONSIBILITY. AND
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM THEY
WILL USE AN ELECTRONIC FORM-
AND SO IN THE LONG TERM WE CAN
BE CREATING IT IN EFFICIENCY-
THAT IS GOING TO BE A HUGE
BENEFIT FOR THIS ENTIRE PROCESS
FOR STATE FOR TAXPAYERS- AND SO
NAY APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS BUT
I THINK THAT THIS IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. WELL WE
ALSO GOT A WORK ON BIRD MISTER
BAILEY. THANK YOU MY QUESTIONS
MAYBE FOR THE AG'S OFFICE AND A
KIND OF TRAILS AND WHAT'S BEING
DISCUSSED HERE CLEARLY IN YOUR-
BACK UP THE INFORMATION AS THE
SPONSOR OF THIS THAT YOU
PRESENTED TO US AND WE HAVE. A
COPY OF YOU YOU SHOW IN THERE
THAT THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S
OFFICE HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
REALLY PERFORM DOING THIS
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF FUNDING
WITH RESPECT TO THIS YOU ALSO
IN RECENT YEARS HAVE SHOWN THAT
THE FIRE MARSHAL HAS DECLINED
TO REVIEW A NUMBER THE
CERTIFICATIONS BECAUSE OF THAT
LACK OF FUNDING. YOU'RE
STEPPING UP AND SAYING YOU WANT
TO TAKE THIS ON BUT YET YOU'RE
NOT ASKING FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDS AND USE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL MEMBERS THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE SOMEWHAT OVERLOOKED
LOADED AT YOURSELVES. AND I GET
THE AUTHORS- COMMENT ABOUT
MAYBE SOME EFFICIENCIES EXIST.
WHICH BEGS ONTO A LARGER
DISCUSSION SOME OF THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS DON'T HAVE THE SAME
BREATH OF- FUNDING THAT YOU DO-
FOR THE- ENHANCED- TOOLS THAT
NEED TO EXIST THROUGHOUT OUR IN
STATE SYSTEM. BUT HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO HANDLE IS. WITHOUT
ASKING FOR MORE FUNDS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION THAT'S A
VERY VALID QUESTION FIRST OF
ALL THE TO TURNING GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND MORE SPECIFICALLY
THE TOBACCO SECTION WITHIN THE
TOURNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
ALREADY REVIEWS THESE MATERIALS
AS PART OF HIS ONGOING UNFORCED
MEANT AND ADMINISTRATION OF THE
STATE TOBACCO DIRECTORY SO- IT
REALLY IS NOT GOING TO BE
ADDING TO OUR EXISTING
WORKLOAD- BUT IT MAKES FOR A
MORE EFFICIENT SYSTEM. BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE TO ASK THE
MANUFACTURERS TO SEND US WHAT
THEY'VE SENT OVER EXTRA COPIES
SENT OVER TO THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE AND- FRANKLY
THE- THANKS TO THE VOTERS IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN- PROP FIFTY SIX
DOES GIVE- THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FUNDING FOR A NUMBER OF
TOBACCO RELATED- WORK INCLUDING
THIS TYPE OF WORK AND THERE IS
NO CONFLICT OF INTEREST FOR YOU
WITH RESPECT AND NOW YOU'RE
PLAYING A MULTIPLE ROLL PART
WITH RESPECT TO. THIS ENTIRE
REQUEST. FOR EXAMPLE YOUR SAID
JUDGE JURY AND EXECUTIONER IN A
SENSE- WITH RESPECT TO THAT AS
THE EIGHT GB. I DON'T I DON'T
VIEW TAKING ON THE ROLE OF BOTH
AN ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTION AND
ENFORCEMENT AS APPROPRIATE AS
BEING A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
THAT IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT IS DONE IN MANY OTHER
AREAS INCLUDING OUR TOBACCO
DIRECTORY. OKAY. HI I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE SENATORS CAME.
THIS MORNING. ANY OTHER A
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. SEEING NONE
ALL JUST ADD REAL QUICKLY MR
BIGELOW AYE CURVE THE CURRENTS
WE SAW A SIMILAR SITUATION WITH
THE WATER BOARD- WHERE WE HAD-
WHAT I WOULD DEFINE AS CONFLICT
OF INTEREST EVEN IF THE AGENCY
FOLKS DON'T ALWAYS SEE IT AS A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST. SO IT
CERTAINLY IS A CONCERN AND
LEGITIMATE ONE. I THINK IT ALSO
MISTER IF I COULD JUST I THINK
IT BEARS. ADDITIONAL REVIEW BY
AS AN MAYBE IT BEGS THE
QUESTION IS SHOULD SOMEHOW WE
POLICE BACK FOR REVIEW AFTER A
PERIOD OF TIME TO SEE IF IT'S
REALLY WORKING TO ITS- INTENDED
WAY. I'M SURE THEY OPEN TO THAT
AND- FOLLOW UP WITH YOU OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE. WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
TRACTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX GRAY. GRAY I AM BIGELOW NO
BIGELOW NO AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I'VE BERMAN BERMAN
I A BONTA BONTA AYE BRO. ROLL
NO COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER
COOPER AYE DALY DALY AYE
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NO GARCIA.
GIPSON GIPSON HI JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY NO
LACKEY NOTE LOW LOW AYE MATHIS
MATHIS NO VOEPEL. QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RIVAS RIVAS AYE
IT RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS
I. FIVE THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN
IT'S OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN UNTIL ONE THIRTY FOR
MEMBERS DOWN ON. MYSTERY THIS
SECOND ITEM HOPEFULLY BRIEFER
THAN THE FIRST HI MR GRAY-
MISTER CHAIRMAN. SO THIS BILL
WOULD SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN- THE
BILL WOULD STRAIGHT. WOOD ASTRI
THEN CLARIFY THE EXISTING
TOBACCO- DIRECTORY STATUE O ME
CALIFORNIA'S OBLIGATIONS UNDER
THE MSA MASTER- THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT- THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY EXISTING LAW TO EIGHTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ENFORCEMENT
OF THE MSA- OBLIGATIONS BY
MAKING SURE TO AT THAT BY
MAKING SURE THAT WE TARGET
NONCOMPLIANT BAD ACTORS THAT WE
SHARE DATA WITH. OUR GOVERNMENT
OUR GOVERNMENT AGENCIES FOR
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES AND SO
WITH M AGAIN OUR SOME
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE TURN
JONES OFFICE- THEY'RE ERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND SO
CERTAINLY- UNDER THE MSA I
SHOULD SAY REALLY BRIEFLY IT
PROVIDES FOR SUBSTANTIALANNUAL
PAYMENTS TO OUR STATE- IN
PERPETUITY WHICH HAVE EXCEEDED
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION IN RECENT
YEARS. AND SO- WITH THAT AGAIN
THIS IS- A BILL TO CLEAN UP
SOME LANGUAGE BUT WE HAVE THE
AG'S OFFICE THAT'S QUESTION.
OKAY SEEING- ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY I DON'T THINK I SEE
ANY- ANY PUBLIC SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE ANY PUBLIC OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE NUMBER TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS SEEING NONE WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
DUE PASSED TO JUDICIARY. GREAT
HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO
AGUIAR-CURRY FIND AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BERMAN. BERMAN I BONTA
BONTA AYE BRO. BRO NO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER I'D
DALY DALY AYE GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER NO GARCIA GIPSON
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I'D LACKEY NO LACKEY NO
LO LO IRATE MATHIS MATHIS NO
VOEPEL. VOEPEL NO QUIRK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA AYE RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RUBIO RUBIO EYES SALAS SALAS I.
THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN ENDS UP.
OKAY MEMBERS THAT BRINGS US- TO
A CLOSE ON A REGULAR ORDER
BUSINESS WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND GAVEL DOWN. GET READY. FOR
SOMEONE TO COME IN ON CONSENT
WE WERE GONNA RETURN- TO THE
ROLE ON BOTH BILLS ONCE THROUGH
FOR MEMBERS WHO ARRIVE LATE.
SEARCH A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ABSENT MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY SIX. AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
SIX ABSENT MEMBERS GARCIA.
VOEPEL VOEPEL NO. HELLO OKAY
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENSUS AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
FIVE BONTA. BONTA I COOLEY
COOLEY AYE GARCIA. GIPSON
GIPSON HI LO LOW I MATHIS
MATHIS I VOEPEL VOEPEL I. I SEE
THAT OKAY WILL CALL SIR TO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON AB SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN.
GARCIA. OKAY THAT CONCLUDES OUR
REGULAR BUSINESS WE'RE GONNA
GAVEL THAT DOWN. WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A TWO MINUTE BREAK MEMBERS
THAN THE SENATORS ARE GOING TO
JOIN US FOR OUR JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON SPORTS
WAGERING